Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so still no face
cam just because this footage dropped So quickly
I cut myself shaving this morning.
So no face cam till tomorrow probably.
There is an injustice 2 giveaway that just
started for a copy of the game so that will
alternate with the reverse flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a flash related comment on this
video winners are announced at the end be
sure to click that bell to enable alerts so
that you don't miss anything.
But this just gives you a little more story
and context for why Barry wants to go back
to the future the raw hanging out and Barry
in irises new apartment that they teased at
the end of episode nine and Barry and Iris
living together you can see that they're totally
get it on.
So if you enjoy that there's going to be a
little bit of that and you have the killer
Frost stuff where they want to try and change
her future to, so this is all back to the
future in the name of changing everyone's
destiny.
But as we've learned from the reverse flash
any time you try to change time to try to
avoid some big catastrophic event time finds
a way to replace that.
So their fixed point in time and then there
are things that you can change, but the problem
is is that it's not always clear what you
can change, and there's actually some really
cool upgrades that YouTube is giving me that
I'll explain at the end of the video to, so
the real danger here is in Cisco fighting
them back to the future Barry trying to change
all the things that he does that might lead
to that actually end up leading to that so
self fulfilling prophecy.
They did say that Barry was going to get crazier
and crazier with the things that he tries
to do to try to avoid irises future, so it
makes it sound like they're going to go back
to that moment more than once this episode
will probably answer that question the most
like will probably be very reluctant to go
back to that usually irises the voice of reason
but she's freaking out here to do in the time
vault.
So, were back to the future newspaper he was
showing Oliver this during the big crossover
episode but we might see is just like during
season one when time change just a little
bit.
The reverse flash Checking the newspaper to
see how things had changed, so they were like
little minor edits that happen was had to
keep track every time he looks at this newspaper
again.
But I think the idea here is that their kind
of teasing is that no matter what Barry does,
this is always going to happen.
So he's in at the find some other solution
they announced that the black flash is coming
back in the back half of the season.
They didn't say when they didn't say what
is going to be doing.
But that might have something to do with this
avatar plot because savitar is a speedster,
the black flash means the death of one of
the speedsters Barry might try to repeat the
big twist of the season two finale when to
use the time wraiths to get zoom but for those
that are wondering like how fast Barry got
like of zoom was supposed to be the fastest
you remember that he was losing speed very
was getting faster and faster Barry himself
is actually like a battery for the speed force,
so he can be as fast as he wants he can manifest
any powers that he wants but just like a videogame
he has to sort of unlock those abilities with
experience in the adventures that he has,
so sometimes like of time changes was can
get rollback or his big weakness.
You know like big heroes tend to have big
weaknesses is Iris.
So that's gonna causing to make all kinds
of crazy decisions and then you have the Wally
storyline, which is kind of a separate thing,
but there looping it back around to like he's
learning to be the flash needs a mentor like
Barry, but because Barry's freaking out about
Iris he's doing a terrible job, so in the
episode like the whole thing is them capturing
plunder who's one of the rogues from Geoff
John's air in the comics he was part of that
future news broadcasts, so Barry sees him
and thinks oh my God.
If we capture him it might lead to this future
event.
So he's a little gun shy Wally steps and steps
into the limelight a little bit and that causes
some of the tension that we've seen in the
other clips like this voluntary flash let
him know that though it's three just about
the wonder in iron Heights his real name is
Jared gorilla turns out he's wanted for string
of robberies from here*sit Wally what was
your supposed to shadowing weight.
You met me at the observe and learn you so
want to save your life shy Wally, but if you
can learn to follow orders to steal between
us it's over all if you didn't know, this
is coming back next week all the DC shows
are coming back next week legends of tomorrow
is moving to Tuesday nights, what's probably
going to happen, is this is going to be my
tentative video schedule now like it just
depends on what ends up happening on those
days is something really big.
Like this morning the injustice trailer drop.
So if you like I had to do a video for that
things will always adjust just a little bit
according to what is up happening so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see the videos upload you get everything
just fine, but you can follow me on twitter
and Facebook I usually post updates.
It's @awesomemergency on twitter, it's /emergencyawesome
on Facebook.
There's so much huge stuff happening in the
back half of the season we have our gorilla
Grodd two-part episode working to meet other
versions of the flash from the multi-verse
people that we haven't seen in a while are
going to come back like I just did a video
about Eddie coming back.
So there's so much happening really like the
black flash should pry the thing I most excited
about.
But this is all about Barry versus savitar
just these first couple of episodes is him
trying to change the future, so we gotta figure
out what the going to do about killer Frost
Heather can prevent her from turning against
the team going off on her own and keeping
Iris alive and well till season for, so whether
or not Barry figures it out the temporary
Band-Aid is to actually stash Iris inside
the speed force grant Gustin posted this picture
that was completely green screen.
The heading here reads that it's for episode
13.
So it's not for a while but it makes it sound
like he's going to be going into the speed
force or something really crazy is going to
happen where they have to include a whole
bunch of special-effects to like whatever
it is gonna be pretty crazy like Jay Garrick
is explain the mythology of the speed force
a little bit going to push deeper into that.
So you'll be seeing new flash powers titis
the new suits of the going to be all kinds
of upgrades happening I can't wait to see
it.
So you have any requests for flash bonus videos
in the next couple days, just leave them in
the comments you want me to explain any concepts
or anything in particular, but the pry be
some more arrow footage tomorrow so I'll post
that I know there's a lot of Prometheus questions
but I'll say congratulations to the first
injustice giveaway winner set easily.
Please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
So there's a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner the next time
I post a DC video.
Just explain those YouTube upgrades.
YouTube is giving me some new features will
help me communicate with you guys when there's
not a video to post.
So like a lot of times it's harder for me
to communicate with the schedule is how things
are changing.
If something happens if I don't post a new
video because a lot of you don't follow me
on twitter and Facebook, so one you can fix
that now, but is also like a new section on
my YouTube channel that they're going to give
me with some new features that will happen
this spring there also going to be fixing
alerts to the little be a lot easier for you
guys to get videos without getting bogged
down, with like thousands and thousands of
comments so all that stuff will be happening
in the next couple of months we a lot awesome
flash stuff coming on bossa movie stuff from
DC and Marvel and.
A lot of cool YouTube stuff that's happening
hwile you guys wait for that next video you
can click here to rewatch the injustice to
play with all the trailer and you can click
here for the next legends of tomorrow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys next video!